the cold war was raging during the
summer of 1972 when reigning world chess
champion boris spassky of the soviet
union met american challenger bobby
fischer in iceland
in bobby fischer ghost war bbc
journalist john eiden now details the
match and its high stakes geopolitical
context the program's 45 minutes
i would like to introduce tonight's
speaker
who
well i'll leave it up to your judgment
as to which adjectives you would like to
apply um
the author of
the bestseller of it constance poker and
tonight's book bobby fischer goes to war
john eidnow
well michael thank you for that
and thanks for inviting me to the store
to talk about our book i'm very happy
that you read wittgenstein's poker in
two sittings i only wonder what took you
so long
but
i'd
like to start with
wittgenstein's poker as you've mentioned
it
and perhaps just say how that came about
and then how we managed to get in from
writing
about a quarrel a sharp interchange
between two
leading philosophers to a chess match
between two leading chess players
and
how did david get to write together at
all
i used to
present programs for the bbc
and in particular for the bbc world
service
and among the programs i presented was
one about british politics it was a
regular weekly roundup of british
politics called people and politics
and i presented it over the years and
producers came and went and i presented
the program one of the producers who
came i was very happy to say and sorry
when he went one of the producers who
came was david evans
and we were riding a train down to a
seaside resort
one summer
in the course of doing our program
together to one of the british
uh
political party conferences
and
i did what a lot of bbc people do to
make conversation i talked about
something i'd heard on the bbc that
morning
and what i heard was a news report
about the pope visiting ghana
and the news report had said
that this was the first time
a reigning pope
had visited
ghana
and i said to david
in my sub editor's way
i thought the word
reigning
was redundant because there was no such
thing as a non-reigning pope
it's an office held
and till death
and we got into a conversation about
this around us were these amazed
delegates going to their party
conferences listening to this
conversation about reigning pope
uh in the course of that i learned that
david had studied wittgenstein
at
oxford where he was
and
so later i went going remains that
argument but later i saw some
correspondence about the incident at the
heart of wittgenstein's poker this very
very sharp fierce interchange between
ludwig wittgenstein and karl popper and
the question whether karl popper had
lied in his autobiography about that
incident
the book is a detective story did he lie
but i saw some correspondence about it
in the times literary supplement leading
british journal literary journal weekly
and i cut it out and sent them i cut out
the letters and sent them to david to
amuse him
and out of that came our book
wittgenstein's poker
which we were very happy
surprised and happy that it had the
success it had
so the question then arose of another
book
we had got on writing the first one
together
it's been enormous fun very demanding it
was like having a long conversation with
somebody over two and a half years that
we wrote the book this long conversation
had gone on extremely enjoyably
and we had written wittgenstein's poker
so what next
and david was uh who still works at the
bbc was doing a series on the world
chess championship
and he contained
a short reference quite short reference
to the 1972
world chess championship between the
american
bobby fischer and the soviet world
champion boris spassky
in reykjavik the tiny capital of the
tiny state of iceland stuck out there in
the north atlantic and when he mentioned
it to me and we'd be discussing what we
might do next
a bell rang
this sounded like something we ought to
take a look at
uh
the most notorious chess match of all
time we started with that
and having done the book and looked at
other chess matches we think that's
still true
over 30 years later this match the most
notorious match chess match of all time
why was it so notorious
so we moved from a little incident
perhaps 10-15 minute incident in a small
room in cambridge
uh but sharp discussion between two
philosophers in front of about 30 people
we have moved from that
to looking at a world event
uh played out in reykjavik over two
months
uh in front of the world's press
that made quite a change for us
but
uh victorious why was it
that this
world chess championship of all world
chess championships and after all it had
been going
since 1880
why did this match for the first time
take the headlines
why did it share the front pages
with vietnam
with the dawning watergate affair
in britain it drove the
ferocious events of northern ireland in
that summer off the front pages
for the first time the bbc broadcast
chess
in new york
there's nearly a riot when a bar owner
wanted to switch to a world series game
rather than carry reports it made stars
of chess commentators they came out of
church halls
and
dark chess clubs up flights of wooden
stairs to become
to become
commentators and stars in their own
rights
chess became the rage it's what you
talked about your friends people who
didn't know anything about chess placed
bets on the outcome of the match
why
and where the explanations given for it
then
were they right
when david and i write
we like to get to where the action was
uh our process is really one of
interrogating the past
obviously to interrogate eyewitnesses to
interrogate the documents we would like
to get along to the places themselves
in this case
we went off and sat in the hall in
reykjavik where the match was played
and talked to the icelanders who ran it
we went up to the great keflavik u.s air
base
and
looked at where bobby fischer went night
after night
to bowl
and to eat american steaks and drink
american milk
and feel happy that in this one place he
could be sure the soviets weren't
getting at him you know sending out
electromagnetic rays to poison his teeth
we went there
we went to moscow
we sat in a former village exclusively
reserved for
writers and artists
in the
dead winter
silence of the moscow woods
we sat and talked to boris baskey's
second wife
larissa
about her relationship with him about
him
about her view of the match she went to
reykjavik and was shocked by what she
found when she got there
that the boris who had set off for the
match so full of health
was now gaunt sleepless
she thought he was being got at
a highly educated woman to this day
believes that
someone
uh
somehow
was
influencing her husband
was it drugs was it hypnosis was it
parapsychology
that something was happening to him
and joy of joys
we sat with the former deputy minister
of sport
of the soviet union uh victor andrew
chivonin
and i held in my hand
what i think
is a unique document of this match
his daily diary
of the events
as sports minister he was actually in
charge of 18 sports he was a real
communist apparatchik and i may say like
so many he's doing pretty well today
now the soviet union is over he's deputy
director of the russian national lottery
has a nice big office he has a car he
has a chauffeur has a bodyguard
and he has the diaries that he kept
throughout his ministerial life
uh
handwritten everything that passed
through his office he wrote down at the
time there could be no better source
of what the soviets were thinking and
doing and saying to each other about
bobby fisher about the match about their
own world champion boris spassky
he wrote in anything that came to hand
the diaries for this
match
are actually written in a soviet trade
ministry diary he must have picked up on
some visit
so
with all this interrogating the past we
stood back to look at this match the
most notorious chess match of all time
to ask about
the perception of it at the time and at
the time of course it was notorious
because
first of all it was seen
as a cold war match were back in 1972
a cold war match
and bobby fischer did his best to make
sure the people saw it in that way he
undoubtedly saw it himself in that way
he went to reykjavik he said
to teach those lying hypocritical
russians a lesson
and he believed that just as in medieval
times uh national national leaders
fought it out hand to hand but he he was
like that he was going to reykjavik to
fight it up with the soviets hand to
hand and the press picked up this and
they ran with it
it's a very curious thing because of
course
1972 was the high point of data
a new settlement was emerging between
east and west the skies were filled with
diplomats
flying to conferences
to discuss
strategic nuclear weapons and uh
what they called i remember the phrase
so well mutual and balanced force
reductions i didn't ever got anything on
that but
it was the high point of detont
leading journals on international
affairs declared the cold war over but
not in reykjavik
in reykjavik bobby fischer had gone to
do a hand-to-hand battle
so that was one reason
why it was notorious
another of course was the personality of
fisher himself
all those adjectives that michael read
out was how people saw him the
novelist
arthur kessler
coined a word for him he called him a
meemophant
where his own life was concerned and his
own affairs he had all the sensitivity
of a mimosa
but where other people were concerned he
had all the sensitivity of an elephant
trampling over them
the word the phrase control freak was
not invented then but it should have
been
to be invented for bobby fischer and his
uh
tote desire for total control over all
the circumstances in which the match was
held
so we had to look at that side of it
and then of course there was the soviet
side
boris baskey was seen as a perfectly
straightforward product of the mighty
soviet chess machine
you have to get back into the mindset of
the soviet union where sport was of
course political
the whole purpose of sport was politics
not the games themselves
uh people did sport because it made them
better communists better soviet citizens
it produced concentration
a sense of strategies chess in
particular it also kept them away from
drink
in the evening after a hard day on the
collective farm their natural tendency
to go off and get drunk if they were
playing chess they couldn't really do
that
so there was a chess machine you might
say
that
it started just after the revolution so
you could imagine that they were saying
to themselves communism equals
electricity plus chess
and chess was seen as
exemplifying
uh the virtues of the soviet socialist
system and they had held the world title
uninterruptedly since 1948
and that was seen as showing that the
soviet system worked
uh the one of the contenders for the
world championship mark taimanov
uh fisher rolled over him six nil it was
unparalleled he got a real beating
taiman off from the soviet chess
authorities
he said there were three things that
demonstrated the superiority of the
soviet system
the ballet
the circus
and chess
when boris spassky went off to play in
reykjavik he didn't go simply as a top
gifted world-class chess player
defending of the title he had quite
justifiably won
uh in 1969 in the eyes of the soviets he
went off to play for the soviet union to
exemplify
uh the success of its system and its
virtues soviet chess players were in the
phrase that they used expected to play
in red shirts but was this true of boris
baskey and the fact is nothing could
have been further from the truth
the london times described him in the
match as the usual sort of benign soviet
bureaucrat
behind the scenes nobody saw him like
that
behind the scenes he was seen as
well irritating
is an understatement of a major sort
he was not a soviet patriot quite
deliberately not he was a russian
old-fashioned slavophile russian patriot
he did not believe in the system
he didn't play for the system
he was his own man they found it hard to
decide quite what he was he wasn't a
distant that was for sure
but uh was he a nihilist
um was he an artist
was he a joker
uh there are references in interviews
that were done
for this book in which they talk about
him as though he were that very
traditional pre-zarist figure the holy
fool
so licensed jester
able to say unpalatable things and have
them accepted because of the intense
religiosity but spassky defied the
system had he not been so gifted
he might have had a very different sort
of future indeed
so we had to look at that
and of course we had to look at the
circumstances in which the match was
played
bobby fischer's demand for total control
over the circumstances of the match
uh why the soviets why boris baskey
uh
didn't fight back on that he could have
quite easily have left reykjavik
with the title
having declined to go along with the
demands made by fisher
the icelanders play their part in it
they're a tiny country they invested a
huge amount in the match
they invested so much they could not say
no to fisher
he played chicken with them
and they won and he won
so all this
comes in then into the match itself
the drain on boris bask is nerves and
morale when fischer fails to turn up for
the opening of the match
boris is in iceland his preparation has
not been good there's a lot of worry
about him back in moscow he hasn't
worked hard enough he's played too much
tennis he hasn't taken a full team with
him that he really needed and got a
manager there
he thought they'd be kgb and he was
probably right but they might have
helped
him right the steady drain on his morale
on his energies a fisher does turn up
uh
loses the first game on a blunder a
beginner's blunder spassky isn't fooled
by that
fisher then forfeits the second game
will he stay there's a question would he
go now the question is will he stay
he stays on condition he plays in a
small back room
boris baskey agrees he agrees in one
word he just says in russian that's fine
pojoster okay
and he goes in and gets slaughtered
from then on it looks as though he will
be run over by fischer as fisher has run
over so many people before steamroller
his way to the title but spassky holds
on he hangs in there
there's a remarkable series of seven
draws he can't get a breakthrough he
fights
at the end
everyone thinks that spassky is going to
get sent to the gulag
in fact the word goes out
he must be treated in a civilized way he
lives to fight again
the paradox is it's fisher who
disappears
and forfeits his title
the soviets think that fischer would
have made a wonderful soviet player
you know he's totally focused on chess
nothing else worried him
nothing else was there for him to think
about raspersky would made a wonderful
western player you know he's full of
jokes a wonderful mimic
he likes to get around with the boys
have a good time but it's spasky who
comes back and fights again for the
title
so it's very paradoxical you could say
was this a cold war match
not for the world leaders certainly not
for breezneth the soviet leader at the
time not for nixon not for henry
kissinger
who helped get fisher into the match
it was not for them a cold war match
but in cold war terms there was a
paradox
that it was spassky who has the
character we normally associate with
the west and with democracy
individuality and kindness towards
others
and it's fisher
who has what we've always associated
with the
soviet bloc concerned only for himself a
total concern for himself and none with
others
so this was indeed the most notorious
chess match of all time it's also the
most interesting and the most
paradoxical
and it's all in here
i'm available for your questions
[Applause]
but when you ask a question could you
kind
go to the microphone yes absolutely
um yes it's turned on great um i heard
that after that match uh bobby fitcher
had the highest rating anyone has ever
had is is that true and has anyone ever
gotten that high again i i think that's
right and nobody has ever got this uh
the the way in which they work out these
ratings but he certainly had it at the
time whether he's hung on to it i don't
know i'm ashamed to say no but i can see
a colleague in the audience
has he right
but he certainly had it at the time
the man obviously a chess genius
but he was also totally committed to
chess
even soviet grand masters were
astonished
at his commitment
it even went so far
that uh the final dinner
um
after the match official gets the
victor's laurels you know
and uh the first thing is he goes up to
get the check
and he opens the envelope and reads the
check several times to make sure the
figures are in the right order
okay
and then puts in his pocket and goes and
sits down again no speech no graceful
word of thanks
no acknowledgement of his opponents and
so on and so forth
but other people make speeches in the
meantime fisher moves into a chair next
to the exhausted boris basket pulls out
a pocket chest set and proposes to
discuss with spassky where he went wrong
in the last game
and uh
don schultz the former chairman uh
president of the united states chess
federation
told us about having dinner with uh
fisher that
you have conversation i've done a look
around and fischer would be
playing on his pocket set
they said the only thing wrong problem
with fischer in chess was the necessity
of having an opponent
you know when you played these games i'm
sorry that's all right does that answer
your question yes
is fischer still alive
fischer is still alive at least he's
thought to be still alive and he gives
evidence of being alive in interviews he
gives to a philippines radio station
i don't recommend anyone to listen to
them
they are long
long anti-american anti-semitic rants
he's not been seen for some time after
the match as you know he didn't defend
the title in the end and it was taken
away from him in 1975.
he only played once more in public after
the world chess championship and that
was a rematch
which was done for five million dollars
put up by yugoslav businessman
and it was played in a couple of places
in yugoslavia
at that time
the united states was operating a
cultural embargo against yugoslavia it's
during the civil war
as part of united nations sanctions
and as a result of playing in that match
bobby fischer came under indictment
here in the united states and that
indictment still stands he can't return
but nobody's seen him
we chased him through cyberspace
we got an email address for him
we sent him some emails proposing an
interview
we think he's in japan as i say and back
came a whole series of replies
extraordinarily polite and formal
replies presumably from his intermediary
and then we had one which was different
i looked at dave dave looked at me and
said that's fisher
it was very direct
uh
about the conditions for the interview
and so we did our best to
the lighting the height of the table
um but we then the next step was just
another very formal reply again saying
mr fisher will not give you an interview
boris baskey of course lives in paris
and he's
accessible he's not easy to pin down
because he's a russian and he's always
going to decide tomorrow
what he's going to do
but
he did talk to us
and
is a man of great charm and still
playing a certain amount of
that chess he was about seven or eight
years older than fisher i think yes
right um boris bobby fischer was 29.
though curiously all the people who
worked with him referred to him as a kid
i thought it's very significant that um
he had
new york lawyers looking after his
affairs
and they talked about him as a kid he
was only a kid he was 29 after all
and uh boris basket was 35.
repeat the question i'm sorry how old
was uh i'm sorry yes you didn't make the
journey to the microphone right and i
forgot to ask you apologies to our
colleagues here how old was boris
spassky at the time of the match he was
born in 1937
and had a very hard time um
just after the second world war
what caused him to go he said vietnam i
believe is where he's currently or he
was residing
sorry
where was he resigning he said vietnam
or something
in japan and japan he's thought to be in
japan nobody's actually seen him
i don't think for some time he's thought
to be in japan
he's six feet two
and you would think he would literally
stand out in japan
but um
nobody's actually seen him there are
always these rumors he's busy playing on
the internet but
i think that's thought not to be the
case they're just people taking up his
style he he says he will only play what
is called random chess from now on
what made him change he went from like
anti-soviet to like anti-american
um that i
i couldn't read that into his psychology
he was very anti-soviet from
uh quite an early stage in his political
care in his chess career and that
steadily got worse he was also
anti-semitic from quite an early age and
that has got worse but why he's taken
against your country the country here i
do not know but he certainly has and i
think i was told that his picture has
now been taken down from the u.s chess
hall of fame as a result of the remarks
he made after 9 11.
bobby fischer has
been known to cut off long-term
relationships with any friends who were
willing to talk about him to the press
did you therefore find it difficult to
find and any friends of his who were
willing to talk to you about bobby
fischer
no we didn't have uh a problem
one or two called off interviews with us
because they are intending to write
their memoirs and
they thought their reminiscences should
be for the memoirs and not for our book
um but
others for instance paul marshall his
new york lawyer very willingly gave us a
very complete interview
on it so and david levy a chess player
who stayed with
bobby fischer
after the match when fischer was living
in california he gave us an interview
they i think robert byrne gave us an
interview
so we didn't have any problems with that
but we haven't spoken to anyone who is
currently associated with fisher a we
don't know who they are and b we don't
know where he is did you get a chance to
talk to larry evans who i think may have
been a second yes yes no he wasn't a
second but um
uh he was the second in a previous match
with with fisher and was stunned by
the way in which fischer devoted the
young fisher devoted himself
every hour of the waking day to chess
chess nothing but chess
sorry if you go behind the microphone
you can get in there
i just like to uh introduce myself as
one of the
the the few people who has actually met
the guy i went to high school with him
uh
and actually played a game of chess with
him because this was we were both
freshmen uh
he advised me to resign after about two
minutes
but i recall him as a gangly kind of
strange kid
in brown corduroy slacks and a and a
t-shirt with a kind of very distant uh
spaced out look on his face with three
or four books in russian or german or
whatever on chess under his arm
he flunked geometry twice
and he he left high school uh after his
sophomore year because he wasn't given
leave to to be able to go out and play
in the national championships and i
don't think he went back to school after
that
uh very strange person um and i think
uh
dismissive is another adjective that i'd
add to your list
well thanks the adjective and the memory
of funnily enough i was doing a phone-in
this morning and a caller had also been
at erasmus high
at the same time as fisher he left as
soon as he was able he didn't see the
point of being there
and i i have
some sympathy with him at this point
because
there he is he's already a figure on the
world stage of chess a predictive future
champion he's united states champion
he's been in the candidates matches
and that's his chess life
and then he has to go to school and
share a desk with somebody
and you know be taught
and you think what an unbearable strain
on his personality
that must have been at that time
how did he bridge the two worlds in
which in the one world
he is
seen as this
truly great player with you know all
these adults around him
they're equal and better and in this
other world he's just a school kid i
don't think he did i think he just tuned
out yes absolutely
i have two questions if it's okay with
you um the first one concerns uh
i haven't had a chance to read the book
yet i just got it a couple days ago for
my birthday is there anything new or
previously very
little reported
in the book that
that you can just quickly go over and
the second one's a little bit longer
question so if you want to answer that
one first i can uh
well
uh yes there is a lot new partly because
people are much freer to speak now but
the whole soviet side is new uh nobody
before i mean a lot of the books have
written on the match and when i went to
interview the german referee he very
kindly and in a caring manner told me
there were already 421 books
on the match which was very nice of him
to reassure me in that way
but i think he meant it caringly
uh but a lot of them were in just after
the match
the fact is that we have the soviet side
the real soviet side
uh what they thought about boris
boris's preparation the stresses and
strains embarrass his team how he
quarreled with the two people he needed
most
for his preparation
uh what happened to him
uh how they felt about the course of the
match itself what was being said in
moscow about it all that amore
has not been
seen before and nobody before has had
access to this daily diary by the deputy
minister of sport who was in charge of
chess but again the chess players in the
soviet union
now in russia felt much easier about
talking about it
and
for instance we had details of the kgb
involvement in the match
which have never seen the light of day
before and of course we have a lot about
fisher because people have felt much
freer to speak and also because the fbi
file on his mother
has been released
the fbi followed his mother for 30 years
they thought she was a communist
sympathizer and possibly a soviet spy
and the files are extraordinarily
detailed you can correct some details
about fisher's life in there but also
get their view of him and their insights
for instance there's a lot that comes
out of the file that is new about his
first visit when he was a teenager to
moscow
and one of the reasons perhaps why he
took against the soviets from that age
anyway you've had a second question yes
i did and it's um for those of us who've
played chess for a while concerning the
filming rights of the 72 match
um between an american named chester fox
and the organizers of the tournament
first game of course was filmed and
televised in the u.s and then dispute
came out afterwards and
literally all hell broke loose
that's one of the big reasons why the
second second game was forfeited
in a book that was written
back in 1974 or 75
the author who was a
life magazine reporter
brad darish had written about uh
the filming of it um
abc's wide world of sports bought the
rights and there was one game filmed
after that
but apparently fox had an agreement with
the uh engineer of the
match because all the games were then
shown closed circuit afterwards and
reportedly there is a
complete video copy of the entire match
in a bank vault in iceland
fox went back after the match and the
engineer said pay your bills and he said
no and he never got the film
i wonder if you had found any rumor or
any further information about this
because
you know it was dying everyone in the
west was dying to see this match live
and
were on film and uh they basically got
nothing so i was wondering if you had
found
any new evidence in your research uh
about the films uh it's it is indeed in
here and the icelanders negotiated uh
with a relatively inexperienced and
almost completely unknown in the uh in
the film industry at large
new yorker chester fox
that he had the film rights the
background to that uh agreement is it's
slightly mysterious because it emerged
that fox's name
came up from
fisher's advisory team
and the icelanders certainly suspected
or suspect today
that the agreement was not quite as
straightforward as they have been led to
believe
but
as you said
fischer took against the filming because
he claimed that you could the film the
noise of the film cameras was disturbing
him
that noise was measured with a
state-of-the-art
audio meter
by an icelandic engineer and he said it
was totally
outside the range of human hearing that
fischer could not possibly have heard it
but fischer took against it and that
created the original forfeit and the
problems over match three that move into
the the whole room
uh fox was undoubtedly given the run
around
he had this agreement with the
icelanders but they did not stand up
they could not stand up to fisher
fox threatened to sue
it was all smoothed over there was
obviously no point
as you say other television
organizations came in and they tried to
do they thought they could get an
agreement with fischer but he in the end
you couldn't get that agreement the
closed circuit he didn't have the rights
to
and had no agreement with the icelandic
engineers who set it up
he claimed that he ought to but because
it was purely for close circuit use
inside the hall
he didn't have a claim and every night
the engineer
responsible for the closed circuit
climbed across the roof of the hall
to get the tape of the closed circuit
and to spirit it out of the hall just in
case
someone else chester fox got their hands
on it
that those tapes their terrible quality
if you look at the stool photographs
from them
those tapes are somewhere but no one in
iceland
is prepared to admit that they know even
about the existence of the tapes let
alone where they are
but there's a treasure trove there for
someone
get to wreck you
oh quick question why did uh spassky
choose to stay in iceland
after everything decided to break break
loose
uh why not just go home
uh he
decided to stay in iceland um
it's commonly thought incidentally the
soviet authorities rang him up and told
him to leave and he'd defied them it's
not true that is certainly not true
they were in no position to tell him to
leave
but um he stayed because of what the the
frame of mind in which he went
he went for a celebration of chess
in the russian phrase he went for a
feast of chess
and that's what he thought it was going
to be he was of great admirer of fisher
and liked him
he played him five times before won
three and drawn two
he was totally confident he could win at
the board
his preparation there's no question his
preparation was was flawed
he was in charge of his own preparation
and it was not up to it
uh he went with a quite a difficult team
as well
but
nonetheless he went for the celebration
of chess
and he stayed because he wanted that and
he thought he could win
and that's why he stayed
fisher of course went to to
to declare war
so you have this imbalance right away
there is boris spassky looking forward
to a feast of chess and there is bobby
and he's come to to
declare war
ah well
i'm probably one of the few people here
that has met both of them i'm a chess
player myself i played in the same
tournament with spassky in 1986 and i
met fisher in
1964.
i think one thing i wanted to add that
spassky had a certain amount of courage
tell a little story about him
he gave a big talk in russia they have
these huge meetings where they give
talks about chess
and he was asked a question why paul
carey's never became world champion now
to explain who paul carries was from
estonia
and to give an idea of his significance
in chess they used to have an
elimination term to decide who would
challenge for world championship match
and kerry's finished second in that
tournament four times
and and in answer to this question
spassky said
in public
carries like his country has not been
blessed by fate and to say that in the
old soviet union took a lot of courage
uh
i was wondering if you had that sort of
thing about the uh you've come across
that sort of things when you talked
about [ __ ] the other thing i would
also also want to mention is an answer
previous question
their hat kasparov has surpassed
fischer's highest rating however
kasparov himself actually provided us
put that in a load of context by
pointing out that fischer was further
ahead of his contemporaries than anyone
ever has
and just like people say they're people
who've since become the youngest
grandmaster since fisher became younger
than fish did but fisher didn't just
become the youngest grand master
he became a candidate for the world
championship of 15 and no one has ever
done that
he was extraordinarily gifted
i don't know if he took courage on the
part of boris baskey to
make that remark
that estonia had not had a happy fate
incidentally
he went to paul carris's funeral wearing
a bright red suit
taken by soviet chess players to
indicate his frivolous state of mind
he made that address yes there is a
record of it
in a tarnic kazakhstan called shakti
where he addressed the locomotive
chess club
and he said a number of things in that
address
for instance he said if he had not been
a chess player he would have been a
priest
he also said he thought the soviet chess
players were extremely badly paid
and he instanced that he could go and uh
play in
santa monica and you know win five
thousand dollars but if he played in the
for the soviet union he got
500 rubles for it
it's not quite the exact figures but
something like that
the
local party secretary wrote to the
central committee
uh to the department of agitation and
propaganda
complaining about spassky's speech
and reporting that the audience's lovely
old soviet language the audience had
expressed anger and bewilderment
at what the world champion had said
but what were the soviet authorities to
do about it
okay
he's extraordinarily gifted player
he was at the top of the tree
they prepared to go along with him to
some extent to say well he's irritating
he's foolish he's a free spirit he's a
holy fool
had he not been so gifted they might
have taken a much more sinister approach
because these were not the only sort of
times he made those sorts of remarks
he was a
russian nationalist
a slavophile of a very old-fashioned
sort
um
almost a dostoyevsky and figure figure
in that his personality never really
finished but he was a joker he was a
wonderful mimic he loved
being in company
um
the zombies really didn't know what to
do about him i think
but it's very interesting that
he everyone thought he was really going
to get punished after the match
and it did they did make a very severe
comment on him
uh which is in the records
and i haven't read the book let me just
read what was said about him in the
post-mortem on the match at the end of
the post-mortem the soviet deputy
minister of sport who's chaired the
post-mortem which basque is really
people have really gone for him
makes this
uh
summing up
he says all his requests and wishes were
fulfilled today we can only regret that
these possibilities were not exploited
in full and to the end
spaska's words that the match was a
holiday and that there must be an honest
fight can be called idealism
this was not a holiday but a fierce
struggle
and it is no coincidence that paul
marshall fisher's lawyer
said that victory for fisher was a
question of national and personal pride
unfortunately
comrade spassky did not make such
declarations
but the word had gone out from the
central committee that he was to be
treated in a civilized manner
and he had a nine-month ban from
traveling abroad but he lived to fight
another day and and you will know the
chess players in the audience will know
that he survived to get back into the
candidates round of the world chess
championship
and indeed he got a lot of support
from the soviet union when he played the
true distant and defective victor coach
nye
in a world chess championship match
and pass basket at that point was living
in paris but he still got a lot of
support from the soviets so it's a very
mixed picture but had he been a writer
there's no question that he would have
been offered compulsory psychiatric help
or maybe sent to wheel frozen dung out
in siberia
okay i have to actually step in and be
the bad guy now i'd like to think
john eid now is author of bobby fischer
goes to war it's published by ekko an
imprint of harpercollins on the web at
harpercollins.com
i teach government i teach a civics
class
i use